[Música]
se le atribuye la frase a sócrates
conócete a ti mismo
bastante sencillo suena y a la vez
bastante complicado
me ha gustado mucho esta frase he
aprendido mucho de ella desde que soy
profesor he tenido alumnos como carlos y
alejandra los alumnos muy diferentes
entre sí y muy parecidos y quienes con
el tiempo me han ayudado a conocerme un
poco más en dos aspectos fundamentales
que llegar a una reflexión muy
importante
el primer aspecto es conócete a ti mismo
emocionalmente
con su temperamento maleable y altamente
emocional
carlos no podía ni quería desenvolverse
en una clase que yo daba llamada
pensamiento crítico si no había un ellis
un aliciente emocional de por medio
en cambio si yo le daba una historia o
una metáfora si lo dejaba expresar su
sentir o sus dudas antes que su lógica
carlos aprendía y trabajaba mejor
la mayor parte del tiempo no podía
tenerlo frente al libro de texto cuando
era necesario pero podía tenerlo en una
plática frente a frente conmigo y con
sus compañeros
en ocasiones lo perdí en un limbo entre
su mente y mis estrategias pedagógicas
otras encontraba yo el gancho que hacía
que se interesara de lleno en la clase
carlos sabía mucho de muchos temas pero
se frustraba no poder comprender los
comportamientos de muchos de los que le
rodea vamos
se preguntaba por qué llegábamos a
ciertas decisiones acerca de su vida
estudiantil
y de su propia vida
llegó a preguntar porque tenía que
lidiar con maestros mediocres con papás
poco comprensivos y con directivos
injustos
a la par de que se pregunta sobre su
propio desempeño como estudiante como
amigo como hijo y como ser humano
la herida en la sal fue cuando fue
diagnosticado
y la sal en la herida porque cuando fue
diagnosticado con hiperactividad y
déficit de atención
carlos creía que no podría estar en un
mundo para el que no estaba preparado o
para el que no tenía las herramientas
normales necesarias
sobra decirles que era considerado un
estudiante problema y con la capacidad
para iniciar o involucrarse en un
accidente si no se le tenía bajo
observación
como maestro lo llegué a ver como un
reto como una inspiración
no es cierto lo llegué a ver con mucho
cansancio
como ser humano y ver como un espejo
y algo muy parecido me sucedió con
alejandra
amigable risueña bastante sociable
alejandro le gustaba participar en
carreras pedestres de 10 km la música de
banda y estar platicando sobre muchachos
cada vez que tenía la oportunidad
como su tutor me di cuenta alejandra
comenzó a dormirse en clases a faltar
con tareas ya no a ir a entrenar por las
tardes
esto fue poco antes que se me acercara
para pedirme ayuda para dejar de fumar
para su maestro de inglés sino el
orientador educativo
se tomó la libertad de expresarse y
grito por ayuda cuando ya no pudo más
alejandra como muchos otros de sus
compañeros se después llevar
por un tornado de alcohol drogas y sexo
y como carlos llegó a echarle la culpa a
sus papás a sus familiares y sus amigos
al igual que carlos llegó a creer que en
el mundo no habría quien la comprendiera
y llegó a pedirle ayuda a alguien que
sin saberlo ella en algún momento de la
vida se dejó llevar de la misma manera
con todos mis recuerdos dolorosos y mis
convicciones solamente la escuche y le
ayude en la medida de mis posibilidades
en ambos casos tuve que aprender a
escuchar y tratar de comprender a pedir
el consejo de maestros y orientadores
educativos para poder guiarles claro que
fue regañado y aconsejado de no discutir
me sentimentalmente con los alumnos y de
no hacerme su amigo
sin embargo cuando lo hacía aunque fuese
un poquito me veía reflejado y aprendía
de mí mismo
aunque fuese un poquito
segundo aspecto de autoanálisis fue
conócete a ti mismo socio culturalmente
al haber crecido y sido educado en
escuelas particulares durante mi niñez y
juventud me identifique con carlos y sus
compañeros en la secundaria donde les di
clase
a carros le gustaban mucho los libros
sobre todo los de terror y los de
ficción le encantaban las peleas es real
hay una historia en la que utilizó un
cuchillo de cocina en un receso para
amenazar a un compañero
me gustaba dibujar me gustaba escribir y
le gustaba investigar
llegó a preguntarnos y posteriormente a
platicarnos con a su manera acerca de la
teoría de relatividad y de los hoyos
negros
tenía entonces acceso a libros a
internet ya programas de televisión que
le permitían comprender y dar ejemplos
expandir sus analogías su imaginación y
sus dudas
un maestro y el estudiante que he sido
y fue fácil trabajar con karts y sus
compactos pues compartíamos la
percepción de una realidad y la
accesibilidad a medios que facilitaba
nuestra interacción en clase
en términos socioculturales y económicos
con carlos me fue bastante viable
trabajar
no fue lo mismo fue un caso
completamente contrario con alejandra y
compañía la preparatoria donde los
conocí
y su entorno social requería que más
allá de que mis explicaciones y ejemplos
fuesen comprendidos yo buscará
comprenderlo
tuve que aceptar mis limitaciones y mi
ignorancia en materia de música artistas
programas de televisión futbolistas y
maneras de vivir
una vez se me ocurrió dar un ejemplo
sobre la guerra de las galaxias' el más
sencillo de todos yo soy tu padre
y el grupo se quedó en blanco
tuve que buscar un poco más acerca de la
historia verdadera y del programa del
señor de los cielos y pude sacar mi
gusto culposo por una que otra canción
de música de bandas y entendimos que a
nadie le gusta el reggaeton hasta que lo
ponen
si yo pedía un trabajo enviado o impreso
la mente la mitad de un grupo lo
entregaba y de esa mitad solamente la
mitad lo entregaba como se requería
tuve que aprender y adaptarme a las
normas de convivencia y trabajo de una
escuela pública y ver que en muchas
ocasiones tanto los padres de familia
como los maestros no nos interesamos
tanto por la educación de los alumnos
como quisiéramos como se espera
y me di cuenta que alejandra tenía otras
motivaciones otros gustos otros miedos y
otras aversiones y que tenía que
tomarlos en cuenta si quería tener una
clase más llevadera y productiva
en ambos casos aprendí a analizar sobre
los entornos sociales culturales y
económicos en los que he estado y estoy
y cómo me ayuda ese aprendizaje no
solamente para mi desempeño como maestro
sino como persona
me llevo a platicarles sobre la
reflexión a la que llegue con estos dos
aspectos
conócete a ti mismo
porque no se trata de ti
y aprender a identificar cómo somos y
quién somos con nuestros gustos y
disgustos errores y logros habilidades
destrezas cosas que no podemos hacer es
una tarea a la que debemos aspirar no
solamente como docentes y como padres de
familia sino como seres humanos
para qué
para tener una mejor relación con
nosotros mismos y con quienes nos rodean
hemos llegado a pensar ya estipular que
los alumnos no son nuestros amigos es
verdad no lo son
o mencionaron en una plática exterior
sin embargo no son nuestros clientes o
nuestra fuente de ingresos solamente
la calidad de todas las relaciones
humanas de la enseñanza y del
aprendizaje tiene que ver en el flujo
emocional la interacción y la
comprensión mutua de sus participantes
carlos y alejandra como muchos otros
alumnos me han enseñado que la
vulnerabilidad sobre las propias
experiencias y sentimientos es vital
para establecer una conexión
porque los puntos de vista varían
siempre de acuerdo al entorno y a las
emociones porque los malos entendidos
están a la vuelta de la esquina y el
modo de percibir una realidad por parte
de un maestro y de un alumno no tiene
que tanto con las brechas de edad que
nos separan sino con lo que uno ha
crecido y aprendido a comprender
porque para poder establecer una
verdadera relación o conexión con los
alumnos con los demás es necesario ver
analizar y conocer de uno mismo para
entender que no se trata de nosotros
déjenme compartirles una última
reflexión
albert einstein dijo que para ser
individuos válidos que llegara a sentir
intensamente aquello a lo que
pretendemos aspirar
pero solamente debemos tomar encuentran
en cuenta nuestras emociones nuestros
miedos nuestras motivaciones o nuestras
ilusiones sino también las de los demás
para formarnos una actitud y visión
recta respecto a los individuos ya la
sociedad
estas cosas tan bonitas las logra el
contacto personal entre las generaciones
de estudiantes y nosotros sus maestros y
no los libros de texto
al menos en lo fundamental
eso es lo que representa verdaderamente
conocerse a uno mismo a la enseñanza y
el aprendizaje
per nos por lo menos en los aspectos de
los sentimientos las emociones y el
entorno de los estudiantes vernos más
allá de nuestra preparación o de las
materias que nos tanto nos gusta enseñar
para poder educar mejor gracias
[Aplausos]